(bold rock music)
- My ultimate goal is just
to have my name up there
with my dad's name when they're picking
some of the best drivers in the industry
to work on a big car show.
You know, I don't wanna
be the best woman driver,
the best Black woman driver,
I wanna be the best driver.
I mean--
- One of the best drivers.
- Okay.
- Don't get too cocky,
'cause then I ain't gonna be able to work.
- Ah, ha, ha, ha, you're so funny.
(car engines revving)
My name is Brionna
Lynch, I'm 21 years old,
and I've been a stunt
driver for 4 1/2 years.
- My name is Jalil Jay Lynch, I'm her dad
and I've been in the
business for 27 years.
- All the dangerous stuff
that the cars are doing
in the movies, all the exciting stuff?
We do that and not the actors.
So a couple of the films
that I've worked on
are Black Panther, Proud
Mary, Fast and Furious 8,
Beyonce's music video
Formation, and Creed,
and that's me and my dad right there.
- [Jalil] I got started in the
business doing New Jack City.
I've done all the Fast and
Furious series since number four.
In Jumanji, I'm one of the
guys up there on the bike.
Yep, that's me right there.
- So cool.
- 'Cause I am the coolest--
- 12 o'clocking it.
- Dad ever.
- When my dad and I are working together,
we actually like to help
each other set the cars up,
so when I have to do something
like sliding around the corner,
my dad is right there with
me trying to make sure
that everything is set up, so I think
that's what makes my
dad and I really unique.
(tires squealing)
I got into stunt driving
because of my dad.
He taught me how to ride
when I was three years old,
he's been teaching me my entire life.
He's so good at what he does
and so respected in this industry,
so since I started stunt-driving
he has been my motivator,
my coach, my teacher.
He's everything but my
accountant, pretty much.
That sounds like fun.
- Bang.
One of the things that I had learned
by riding with her all the time
was that she was able
to handle the pressure.
Three, two, one, action.
As much as people don't believe
that you're inside a
car when they explode,
people are in those
vehicles, so it's a lot
to let your kid go and be in danger.
I guess part of being a
parent and part of being
in the stunt business,
we do as much as we can
to keep her as safe as
possible and then after that
you wish for the best.
(tires squealing)
Good job, kiddo.
- I love that I get to share
stunt driving with my dad.
I think that's a really cool
bond that the two of us have.
My dad and I have always been very close.
He's very supportive of
me chasing down this dream
that I have and, if you
wanna be good at something,
you have to put the time in.
It's important for you to enjoy your life
and to actually love what you're doing.
That's the biggest picture
at the end of the day.
(upbeat music)